and the ick is one of those things that
you read about in women's mags women get
the air con meant and not to get the and
what's been described there basically in
colloquial terms is the fact that women
sexual disgust threshold is a lot lower
than men's and that's one of those
things that you can measure quite
objectively because you can measure
people's disgust response through things
like sweating and heart rate it's much
easier to trigger in women than it is in
men there's interesting evolutionary
theories around this I mean it might be
partly to do with the fact that women
care more about it than men do it might
also be to do with the fact that women
tend to be more vulnerable to sexual
disease so women are more easily grossed
out by signs of disease in a potential
sexual partner and that might be because
the nature of sex just means that women
tend to be more vulnerable to disease
transmission from sex and also that
women are more likely to pass sexual
diseases onto their children through
pregnancy and breastfeeding so there's
maybe a more like deeply embedded
instinctive protective Factor there